you
maybe do better than last time we will
see 10 seconds to go here's the list the
top 50
okay here we go
hours of
three minute chests okay
first opponent playing for Chicago's
team
okay
it's a little
it's a little baggy here a little bit
I went with the night off three by the
way because I do have
some games in here against
this player
let's take
maybe I should have captured here first
I'm not sure anyhow I went with this
first he likes to play the Albin counter
gambit taking in this order because
eventually I'm
that I can grab a useful tempo against
the Queen now that she's on a completely
open file
so she'll probably feel bit
uncomfortable at some point playing
trying to play against this isolated
palm
let's go here no longer playing against
an isolated pawn if black chooses to
capture
it's a bit surprising
okay so I could maybe
hanging pawns let's try that
go here actually
probably have to come back over
unless calculating capture capture yes
Queen takes pawn rook C - let's try
Queen takes pawn and then rook c2
and then put my knight here a nice going
to go here
okay actually let's offer a coin
exchange night here worked there could
have been problematic
ah that could be problematic as well hmm
may have to retreat or no it's
let's offer Queen exchange again
hmm
you
[Music]
now let's put the night in the center
Roxy ate
it's a good move
sneak into flights
where what kind of a flight square I
guess this kind
feels a little weird to do this because
well no maybe not I'm threatening a fork
but it's unprotected that's why it feels
a little weird to me mm-hmm
just come back it's tough I don't want
to take maybe you may take once because
they do get a passer on take once and
then no no
let's go here
maybe there was better no it's tough to
say I have this under control
okay let's hit the rook hmm can I do
something dangerous with my Knights with
my night
hmm
my clean maybe could look to cover this
diagonal I'm gonna try to make me let's
just give a check for starters it's kind
of cover some stuff here be around my
king I'm pinning the knight to the pond
maybe I do go ahead and grab that
coordination here I'm slightly head on
the clock wouldn't mind you know trying
to get this in actually a clean exchange
my favorite my favorite
in exchange forced ooh
let's go one step mm-hmm here is that
about uh nice tactic nice tactic you're
going to take that
ah it's a draw oh just go back determine
point zero three each if he did take my
night he would oh my goodness there's
already 79 points put up whoa we're in
second I don't even know who's playing
uh I put up one point I put at one point
okay I don't know uh I don't know what
the standings are for the team I don't
have that information
nor do I know who else maybe jumped in
to play anyhow chess media playing
against I'm gonna take what the pawn I'm
on this now and I think I think it's
been miss played early on these pawned
advances because now I can I kind of get
to easily make use of this square
so let's start with that some
development
and I'm going to try and control this
guy I think you could be experiencing
some difficulty
[Music]
oh here here here
yes here for starters
you
here next
and here let's go here and get the light
squared bishop SIA
some more protection first so what would
I like to have happen I'd like to have
like a knight versus their Bishop
my night here that cannot be challenged
either kind of being sneaky there now
let's take
let's go here
looking forward to an e5 break this guy
could become past I have a check
available cuenca block this rook is a
little awkward has two responsibilities
maybe maybe my knight is challenged soon
the Queen would defend this you know
night be six blocks okay we got clean
there
how bad is it if I get the Queens off
oh let's actually step up little for it
a little bit afraid of night here but my
rook defends this against this night
tactic
so
yeah
maybe maybe get the cleans off is best
I think I still enjoy some advantage
here
some
let's get the Queen's up
my recovers the night
the Night Moves okay go for that
interesting
gonna take with this guy
and then
this feels correct here clean is
defended
so here I'm way down on the clock yeah
yes there is that when it take though
and just lock it up I don't know I think
my night is uh it's kind of
good here
maybe I go after that guy whoa
that's a big
Center
really big
now I don't think that that was a good
choice I don't know should I maintain
pressure here just start pushing pawns
which one do I go with first I guess
that
because the Queen doesn't have squares
over here where the Queens kind of stuck
right you go in here how what are you
doing
could maybe even afford a queen exchange
- right
Oh
[Music]
let's go here first
just looking to push this guy I guess
huh
yeah why not this guy will come here
this one supported let's get this guy
gone
in the sixth-ranked
looking pretty good let's see let's go
here first
maybe even improve my King before I
another step with one of these guys yeah
I don't want to give up a square just
yet I get my king here
okay here and it transitioning that that
check isn't really doing anything is it
though
I don't think so have this stuff
they're giving they're giving some stuff
back
let's take
the Queen from these checks blocking
these files
hm
[Music]
returned
my clean right here on this
take upon
you
it's taken them two moves constantly
there's no perpetual here
give this check
you
ah
oh man my clock
ah oh man Oh
that one stings
it's important to Oh
[Music]
ah that was looking so good not to be
okay who do we have I'm paired up
against chess weebs
ah man
a better job converting that
so active there
a bunch of checks
let's get the e5 movement
no dark square bishop
put some guys on dark squares
all right let's get a flight square
first
I really wanted that game can you tell I
really wanted that one
ma'am
let's go here maybe push that guy
okay take the night
this pawn is
most annoying to this night here
how could I have a force that clean
exchange clean exchange the night is
also supporting that sneaky
oh I guess here
my night gonna be challenged maybe night
here I just back off and say what it
what is the night doing
or how about I just control this night
five
yeah that can't my mind is still on that
that other game how to say
China trying to find improvements to
that last game okay
let's go here
here
you
let's back up
I guess I'm giving up that oh my
goodness I'm missing so much stuff and
even see the night could go there my
blind thinking only then I could go here
who now that nights are real thorn
and see I think f3 is a good move okay
this back off this night should
soon you think f3 because the eventual
coordination on f7
out of that square
just wanna definitely keep this block
hated
I think I want to do without f5 but one
night here maybe I
hi midge
let's get going with this
let's keep going actually and then try
for this a night right here should be
good oh I missed that that was even a
move I want to keep both Brooks on
hmm all right f5 let's go about five
want to get it h3 or maybe f4 something
against the King let's go with that for
oh no no oh yeah it's a good thing I'm
on the clean otherwise there's this it's
a good thing I have a time edge mmm
let's take here I'm on this clean there
yes
let's take here I'm on the Queen and
then here look at the h2 square
oh I'm on that force the Queen's up okay
why'd I go there exactly let's get my
King blockading Yeah right there I
should be able to get this one with the
time edge and time and position okay
back determine who okay where are we at
- hey there isn't that there isn't a tab
here - see I'm gonna try berserk I'm
normally not the berserk enctype but
it's for the team for the team
try to go for h2 I'll see
fishing poles right
you
right so nothing
exciting yet I'm still I'm gonna I'm
gonna go for it okay here only after you
know a night move I could capture what's
check otherwise this is this is bad this
Palmer's back and I played this and
that's what they're setting up so let's
maybe go hear that my Bishop defended it
was like at the moment they're playing
well above their rating i takes knight
how i'll i recapture probably with the
queen alright and let's actually try
this being sneaky if i could gain
control over this diagonal I have some
mating ideas Knight jumping in rook
delivering me that there right now let's
have a look at this move leave this and
then here
see floors may be a good move let's go
here and I'd love to be able to get that
dark square Bishop huh
good move let's go here my knight is
pinned to the Queen all right I guess
I'm going to be losing upon or not Oh
defend the Queen okay
why don't they take in my night they're
okay
there's a tactic
actually there's not I could take here
first
Knight takes Bishop takes Knight takes
rook and then here here here's me
let's go here
Oh Bishop takes pawn with check is
available I could have also grabbed this
pawn
stranor
there's still tricks against my king in
this unprotected bishop on a seven
you
thirty seconds
in a move they're really in the tank
here
here would take care of a check
peace
okay slightly ahead on the clock too
all right just anticipating some
pressure against d6
bishop defend my palm
a ch3 was a move as well
No
determined I got a tree there where we
at
nope right there so that players 544 are
in there okay who are we going to get
next
berserk Kim
Knight of six
see five
so I'm not
quick kill like in the last game
Queen b6 mmm
allowing me to take their I don't want
it there's this counter
against b7
I'm happy with this so far
Bishop ow oh it actually it's a double
berserk
they berserk back so this is from
and they're playing for the Shema Canal
fan club
you
I was going to say I'm happy
bishop outside the chain and i have a
more aggressive c-pawn
let's get this guy here maybe may be
able to win the exchange yeah I think
I'm close to winning the exchange I
could take here on the clean and here
I'm on the clean again and the bishop
a lot of stuff
trying to get another three we'll take
the bishop and
take care on the other bishop
okay am i clean but I could take
beyond they're clean with check
I'm winning some material now a lot a
rook
bishop up
and upon
check here
this nearly it's already a half hour
into the tournament almost a half hour
that me that's me okay bye
have fire
where we at 278 285 335
currently 5th the team here pretty fresh
these are all the streamers I don't even
know I don't think I'm up there in the
top 20
all right let's go let's go with tonight
f6
okay I don't have to worry about this
stuff
yeah let's go here multi-purpose I want
to be able to meet queen bee 3 with
v6 let's also preserve my bishop so
I get my night out alright so so a
standard my standard setup
willing to take on this or play with
this potentially week on
hmm that's interesting
don't take play clean here hitting this
in supporting this advance however
right now mmm I need to get one more
moving ok this move right now is not
working
let's go here
here boom boom there's a there's a trick
watch out for the trick alright let's go
here I thought for a second about
getting this movement and trying to get
the light square bishop Soph if they go
here they're a little weakened okay so
here chop chop
clean here
I can get out of that
get out of that
with night somewhere night 94 gets out
of the pin
and
is also out of the pin if that okay
they're just going for for this stuff I
guess here
I'm very fast minority attack
the big minority attack
okay so I don't know how much is
going to change on this side of the
board
inside
okay
don't take with the phone
if they take my clean
Queen on a3 should be pretty annoying
yeah okay I'm going to try this ending
take here take here and then get the
file
it's not much
so go here my kings going to need to
breathe
both of our Kings need to breathe
they're going to get they're going to
get rolling with the pawns
hmm
my king right here I think would be
pretty sweet
yeah let's just because I could get a
passed on as well
you
yep let's create my own past poem
no no this wasn't calculated
maybe a bad idea
you
you
I don't know how to assess this
you
try for something sneaky I I don't know
file open somewhere else
let's try this
I don't think I've ever had this type of
an ending before it says weird weird
rook and pawn ending
yeah
no no no think I'm maybe just lost
gotta move my king
you
hmm
um ya know I'm lucky if I could even
hold this yeah 25 seconds as well
down on the clock
position not good
I guess try to get the rook behind is
the best and stay in front of this more
central pawn is this the way might be
the way the clock though cut the King
off
of anytime look for me
after my rope
[Music]
oh my goodness I'm so lucky to get a
draw why'd it have to be so hard why oh
man fighting for my life in every game
hm
I need a breather can we get a timeout I
need a breather okay I haven't no idea
where we are here I just don't know okay
who barely barely barely barely these
tournaments
oh no no no no we're going to clean
because this night loves the c3 square
let's stop any trickiness
and maybe mmm
b5 um make a move okay
Who am I playing it okay Chicago fan
club who my opponent is representing
okay night there I may want to close it
up or oh I think I'll take now and then
put the ruck on the D file how's the
queen gonna feel she feels alright let's
go here and land it here takes ya that
Fork is back on
am I just losing a pond maybe
let's go night here take-take-take on b5
take on before and I am just like that
down upon see how easy you see how easy
it is to lose upon
okay maybe it's also easy to get one
back sometimes that be ponds unprotected
after the Queen moves
my hand is cold
right
tricky miss
rook d8 gets a piece yeah
hmm
maybe I'm not getting a pong back
take with the bishop I guess I don't
know
yeah
oh let's go in here
we're going to take with the pawn
try and get some prep oh that night I
didn't realize the Nike get in there
let's go here stop rook-a a
the pond yeah I'm on my back foot now
big time
see 6 I could take here try and break
down this guy
is far superior
better minor piece my opponent has
guess here take this file
now here maybe weaseling on the light
squares c6 now
possibly
you
about here put some pressure on
something I want to restrict one of the
pieces and enough feels active out here
maybe maybe some flight square was was
better
g3 King g2
here I could still take that night is
stopping my Queen from moving forward
Queen here if Knight takes pawn there is
a pin so
probably wouldn't want to go into a self
pin there
okay they're not quite
sure what to do
maybe Bishop here
on here bishop here is an improvement
okay back rank mates might be nearby and
now I could afford to get the Queen's
off because the rook cannot defend they
were floundering there I was gifted a
lot of moves because they were just
shuffling so
could take here
take care
getting this pawn
okay let's back out uh let's get the
Queen's off first oh no no here check oh
no I just dropped my bishop Oh why'd I
do it like that
oh that was so bad
oh man
you
I don't want to all right now I'll do it
you
should be able to time burn my way
I should
okay
okay where we at
oh I don't know I don't know man I need
a team standing tab - no I don't know
it's a mystery okay my opponent
chess media so I'm playing against
right
robbed
we have
let's make an inferior move
a six just I don't know something
different
no I think best is like bishop they're
just developing a knight so I'm happy
with this decision for the decision
white made which is to Fein kettle the
bishop because this in the end is super
solid and if this bishop is to be
brought to life it would mean that c4 is
necessary
so kind of biting on a rock it's an
active piece it's a very good defender
of the king
okay and now I guess I'm gonna stop this
idea they may be looking to establish a
duo G for night here stuff so let's go
here
it's solid
sure I guess well castle I night on this
square could be pretty good too since
white decided to go there let's break
the pin this could be sensitive
opponents going right after it
um is my bishop gonna be in trouble
maybe you know after a chop here push or
cap g4 Bishop takes Knight and then g4
but I'm hoping that I could induce f3
and the king is a bit weakened they're
gonna go for that maybe even get this
guy so this is what I'm talking about
I should probably take first go here
next
and then that way yeah I think this
first
and now this or do I take here first
with check maybe I could do this with
check first and then clean here is very
very close to mate they got a block
very close to me
okay
where are the tricks maybe taking here
is best
you
yeah take there
see
okay
the knight is pinned the dark squares
are very weakened I think I want to hold
this guy back and then drop my knight in
I don't know
this night could use some improvement
mmm
stepping up with my king because of this
rook h8 maybe Queen g3 and then a sack
that could be my plan yeah that's my
plan
just talk myself talk myself into what I
think is a good plan we'll find out
an hour 18 to go all right a Pinter Oni
maybe I should have played it Queen here
first okay
this in the net
let's let's let's try that hits the rook
than here
can only take once there's that night is
pinned so
and about night here now because rook
here there's a fork
where's my night go from here though
I'd like my night here can I make that
happen
no they allowed the fork
we'll take it
and let's go here
now
look into ponds
I want the pot let's go for the pin
second-ranked slight edge on the clock
rook there okay my pieces are swarming
in yeah their nights are not they're not
very good and now I could shop here and
then chop here leading to mate actually
and two of bishop takes
things aren't changing though
here
as a queen check but I can back up
I have Brooke h2 nearby as well
oh let's see
they're in the tank
okay
I could go here
like I'm not converting this in the best
way
okay
yeah when this very very poor technique
I don't know what this is about
just get that guy off oh they didn't
move there they didn't move the king and
about to defend their okay they're down
back determine where are we at here
forth 469 538 596 677 okay crest book
chess club here all right
oh okay so what's the story here
going for quick 95 all right I'm going
here and then here I'll just back up
I am okay if that happens all right my
pieces feel like they're going a little
better no no no here I
allow this I definitely have 200 now
night takes is strong night takes I
think would have been very strong
hitting my bishop and not giving me time
to play this okay
I'm gonna go here because if I end up
with this kind of pawn I'm on my bishop
around to support okay maybe I just take
here whoa okay let's go here
let's see
put the nine
pin first I don't want to pull my king
away just yet
I'm kind of sensing there might be an
advance here if I do that whoa that was
a big miss hole they were they were just
expecting me to take with the pawn okay
that was a quick I think a fairly quick
win here here we out here 590 or in the
team here standings 573 okay 573 is what
we're trying to catch all right let's
try to keep this streak going here I
think I'm on fire I don't know there's a
lot of stuff I don't know you know
tournament standings I'm not sure am I
on fire I think I won the last two games
yeah all right we'll take and then I
guess here castle everybody's nights are
looking pretty sweet I like that move
nice let's go here I think I'm being a
little sneaky not really I'm just gonna
lose a poem um my idea was if they ended
up capturing there I was gonna do
something like this the pin they get
that I get that I think I could still
try for trifer try for that Queen f8
might have been a good move hmm 'if i've
gonna be a move i wanted to do something
like this
think I need to centralise first
you
maybe this
okay light-square bishop exchange
yeah
you
hold off on the I think the rook
position is far too strong they're able
to double
if I go here
let's try it
bishop here here bishop here I think I
have to get I'm gonna be winning upon
gotta go here now right I got this
covered
I'll you're going there all right all
right I could do check let's take here
though
take here night they're here what am I
missing I'm on the night twice I'm on
this as well
hear hear whoa whoa what's going on here
I could take this night here
I'm not sure what I'm missing I'm gonna
be
right and I have a pawn for it
this this could be sensitive dark square
or they don't have a dark square bishop
though my Bishop's ready to fianchetto I
should be going on the offensive here so
like this think forces the Queen's off
no that's check though
and let's throw in another check
now I guess I'm going to say it's okay
allow this because I have a check and
then the king is forced here that I
could take
and I'm on the rook twice so this nights
gonna be able to go here the Bishop's
gonna be able to go here the kings in
hot water soon I'll have these two oh I
missed that I was on that to the
probably resigned they resigned okay
back to tournament where we have 529 607
six okay cool
this is going by really quick here mer
at zero-nine I'll try try the Sicilian
here I guess maybe we go go fishing like
in that earlier game that I berserk
okay let's go here first I don't know
does it really matter what order
with the night there
I'll hold off on h5 in this one Amy whoa
okay
go here Oh No
this square I'm on this poem I break
do I break I'm gonna say yes even though
I'm a little underdeveloped here King
still in the center
I would love to get my night right here
hitting that guy okay
um
you
let's go here
mm-hmm
yes I didn't voice it but this is what I
was kind of crunching the numbers with
Bishop move I saw I have the check to
defend the knight and then I can safely
castle so my opponent has three ponds or
the piece yes they do
let's go here watch out for made on h7
clean there soon this is the
this is the flight square I want anyhow
dark square flight square
Knight or queen being able to take
advantage the hey they're giving me
another tempo so what the rook that is
on a closed file
and what about do I grab that beep on
you
that's the heart I go after the heart
well go all the way back now there is a
discovery but I don't think there are
any good discoveries by the night
oh there is that one yeah there is
okay I missed that one
whoops I forgot that they were
nated there that was a mess so I look
into ponds versus Bishop Knight
you
I need a flight square
right in the center down on the clock
here
white square
here
okay I think I have Courtney
I think I do I'm on the rook threatening
me one that's nice
mrs. crest book chess club Murr at
zero-nine is playing for
about here
twice
and get here
actually let me grab that guy that
outside pass pawn
doesn't have to work as hard to hunt
them down if it comes to that
alright this guy isn't this this guy is
super he is very good
I take care of my
end up in this pin you know let's go
here my rope can continually be pushed
around
No
I gotta get rid of their Bishop I think
ooh
just wanna get rid of their bishop
you
the rook and pawn okay now I could Oh so
sneaky you are so sneaky
takes bishop is there
in f3
whoa take that though
I'm up a piece
you
let's check
it's a check at my pieces running here
I can't go too far
a passer bishop here
on h2 twice even on the clock
careful bishop
the bishop
close to mating it
okay
just cut the king up
next
whoo okay 569 588 665 727 792 okay just
a little over an hour to go
where we adhere this is these are the
standings okay
that's your quick limps der Michael all
right yeah let's see press book Chess
Club again
stick with d5
okay they are gonna fee and keto I'll
give them an opportunity to change the
kingside structure no no captured they
say
let's maintain
two central pawns
you attack me
Center Panama I'll defend
with
my c-pawn there okay
I think I want to just get rid of my
light square bishop it's kind of silly I
don't know what kind of productive role
that guy will have I guess centralize
and play within this structure looking
to be a maneuverer a 3 B 4 may be an
idea this night I'm trying to control
some I think they go for a three I'll go
here and reason that you know that I
don't see a way that b5 could be taken
advantage of though he 3 a 3 a 5 this
might be the this might be the plan but
uh let's see if okay they're not going
for that so let's go here
it's also let's go here actually I want
to be able to guard this diagonal so I'm
prepared to take with my king and if
there's a check now I could play queen
up 6 it's a good move
alright I guess we're gonna take here
and let's move this night I don't want
to get I'm stopping this right now cuz
or mi no I'm not alright I'm securing my
night maybe a little bit from Bishop
stuff ok yeah so I was saying
was a move because I would have been in
a pen so I'm basically saying yeah you
got me here on the C file you're better
so maybe I could do something else okay
so now I have Queen up six I'll let this
is in dive an anything fancy over here
I'm gonna step up with my king no checks
one day no promotions with checks one
day it's kind of how I see it
okay prepared to come at me here with g4
maybe I maybe I come over here do I have
a drive a trick on this square one day
maybe
no let's just bluffing I'm just kidding
oh right remember remember what my queen
was doing on e7 yeah she's not there
anymore
all right Knights are gonna have to find
different squares soon here feels a
little weird I'm gonna keep it on the
king´s side I go here the bishop would
play to e2
my nights are pretty good I think I'd
like one rook off can I get that and try
for maybe get something here happening
what about this I care about that
here is threatening Knight takes pawn
let's go here if Knight here there's a
disconnect between the rooks these guys
are connected okay I'll take one I don't
know let's just mmm let's go here
you
not quite sure what it's doing it's
telling the Queen down okay gotta come
back I guess um let's sneak in I think
okay there's tricks on both of these
squares maybe a queen here I have this
ooh ooh there might be there's there's
something close maybe there rook here
okay there's got to be something not
here but Knight takes pawn if the King
moves I still have this because of this
I think I'm getting something this here
to unmasks the Queen these guys are all
in on this or maybe something here but
as far as trying to safeguard the King
there they're committed offensively and
he's really in the tank to I don't think
there's a good solution at night takes
g3 that's the thing
yeah so this
and now
this I can afford night I can allow
Knight takes pawn there
you
here
now there's rook takes pawn here there's
a push like a block with the knight
this I could take
checkmate next
whoo okay where we at 611 635 718 779
okay let's try to keep up here under an
hour to go let's try an e for a game
one's try e5 inferior okay they're not
trying to get their uh their Bishop
outside the chain so ooh what's that
about
that's odd
that's really odd
okay
[Music]
I keep this pawn around and here
really
Wow
all right I'm taking the
and taken that
this castle so where's Wow
so dangerous
how can you play that move so fast
this and then here
fast really fast
show that break
sting
you
they just want that bishop on this long
diagonal I understand
not just alright if that happens
maybe maybe not okay let's take with the
bishop I was I wanna go with the Queen
first
clean here
keep the bishop defended
and see any great discoveries Queen here
I have this right
let's go here
a seven I'm on a lot of stuff here
actually
take what's cheque
taking their I could take
check
and now I mean I feel like I should have
mate
put this guy here learn a pin rook takes
there it's my idea
queen is very active
[Music]
Oh No let's go here actually
can hear this I'm threatening this and
then this or maybe just Bishop here
first I got to watch gg7
[Music]
yeah they're forcing the Queen's off but
exchange Queens and then get their rug
yeah
let's insert this check first
okay now there's no
no fear
I have this
these are both hit now
okay they should be clean
okay they resigned back to tournament
where we add six 637 659 that is
definitely catchable let's let's stick
with it here uh let's go with I guess a
d4 game
you
all right c4
hmm
this is intense these tournaments are
intense Rebecca Harris is up there as
your top 13 that you could see
okay I'm prepared to part ways with the
pawn if they want to grab upon they
could do that they don't want to do that
let's go here keep the pin
Mack Plast is the opponent
chess club
okay let's take care first because now
if this I have that getting the bishop
and then in the end winning some
material yes I'm winning some material
now
I take here and then take here with the
four Corona
okay so I'm getting some material and
now try to do something dangerous with
this unopposed dark square bishop on
placing a constraint now and the queen
just defend that night now the night is
in a pin
go forward or maybe setting up this
stuff
night out of here
yeah here bishop here now that out the
f-pawn advance is up there have cleanup
mm-hmm or do I
yeah I do okay I've cleaned here clean
here I was thinking here initially but
short-lived
so I'm on the night I think he just has
to run in Reverse now and now I can
chase the Queen officially away from
this G file so then I could win this
piece my knight has these two and the
pond has the other all squares covered
back to tournament they resigned
okay 659 683 51 to go 683 sick man boo
boo it's very tight there in the top two
jaggus zero one berserk Inge rockin
berserk back
right
still go with this this little build
take
back by force
yeah
this threatening a fork what is it with
meaning these Forks here
once again threatening a fork
let's go here
whoa isn't this very good to establish
this pawn here
I even need to do that
this move isn't available if this you're
just welcoming this stuff so here
I can play Bishop there maybe
what's that about
not sure what that was even threatening
go here
yeah
just secure
this
okay that was that was bad
would I right-click in a viewed source
there okay I think I think we're back up
and rolling here stay focused now I lost
a lot of time there
[Music]
I'm dropping upon oh it's so easy now
for white it's a lost King and pawn
ending and I'm still in a pen
oh man yeah ah it's just too easy
just too easy now don't know that yeah
it's still gonna be a win maybe not
because this pond restricts these two
I know is it maybe a draw now
you
No
oh yeah man
frustrating
was frustrating their c5 boot was very
good I didn't I didn't voice that but
opening up that diagonal towards my King
was very good valera b5 getting berserk
all right Valera this beast super fast
super strong all right
yes diving right in to those weaknesses
I see I see
No
challenge that night
getting the pond huh
hmm
[Music]
okay do I even want to take that and
take that challenge that night stopping
me I was ready to move my night there
scary my king here it's a strong move
don't have that mm-hmm let's take try to
get rid of
night okay my night would like to be
where somewhere else here
surprise they captured that why they
capture that
stop king here
you
a tough call to take or not
you
and go to
you
we push push and then take here
the plan
you
stop the push I think they should have
pushed first maybe
let's try something different here
for this
is a repetition
might be repetition
it's going to be a draw maybe
you
yes at a main threat
you
oh my god I almost mouse slipped
you
let's go here
you
get that King back
they resigned tough cookie okay
736 758 okay we have a killer here
chess media
do not forget that that was
an opponent who berserk
okay let's go like this can I get this
in
I guess so I have enough support for
instead of castles I think this was a
critical test
[Music]
let's stop Bishop chief for
and
go here I guess
I think d5 is a Moo try and soften up
the queenside I want it on it gain
access to the c-4 square and now maybe
this move it's a little bit more
tempting because this trend with the
bishop here it isn't supporting what
this thematic break nor a knight into
this square
[Music]
I think this night wants to drift over
towards the Queen side in fact a five
let's let's look at look at some squares
over here
[Music]
maybe begin by taking away a square
tonight here right away there's that
uh-huh
let's maintain my Center
shop here there's a check I wasn't even
looking there is a check now that I have
F 3 in there
night here and here is what I want
prove this guy
move and then alright anyhow
I don't think I want to take that night
if it goes there
see that that was a move here now I
could at least block if there's queen
bees no there isn't Queen b6 right now
let's go here develop
be Knight b6 Knight b6 let's just go
back Knight b6 next head light square
bishop exchange my square bishop
exchange my square bishop exchange I
would not mind I could get a knight here
maybe a passer and then a square what's
this night going to do right now it's
kind of silly
see
okay
take these guys are under control right
now
[Music]
take
I could dive in here
can't take twice because Queen d5 hits
with check I get the rook but they could
hit this ball in a second time maybe
clean here rook here do I wear the
tricks I devote my clean here right now
why not
no Queen here is actually pretty good
too I think I like having the Queen over
here hit the knight defend the pawn you
silly guy
and my queens of defends Oh
counter-attack against my knight
good point man you make a good point
that night is doing
centralized
hmm
no I'm on the rook my bishops defending
the knight rook here though
I might have to take that naive No
you
hmm
you
I don't know
[Music]
yeah
my opponent must have something good
here
they didn't take that pawn why not
you
rook there I think I will take that rook
where's my time yeah
you
a night here
you
well I could just take the rook
you
it's mate oh oh man am i lucky
okay 754 792 and then 900 plus the top
three yo okay okay destroyer
Burger King I'm getting berserk again
whoa don't don't play a four in that
position will go f4 here though it's
like French
yeah it is a friend yeah
hey destroyer
let's create three now I'll dance with
the night okay chop away shop away
defend
let's go here a night on this square
should be pretty sweet let's see I think
here take take what the coin yeah I'll
take with the queen force the Knights
off I don't want to see the knight get
in here because then I'll be compelled
to take and then this Bishop we brought
to life so I'd rather a knight exchange
right now and then just blockade a
little bit yeah maybe I can look for
this stuff they're going for g5
Kapali right now they know what queen
was supporting
I don't know not sure not quite sure
what about rook here central temporarily
just looking to pivot force something
okay back off maybe my rook was close to
trapped yeah
okay nothing happening on the kingside
now you raise a good point
I have to play some defense here a
little defense
I don't know if I want my king there I
don't
quite sure I'm floundering these last
couple moves for sure Wow going into a
self pin it's a bit surprising okay
don't mind seeing that get to take
what's check we're back in a pin do not
mind that okay better Bishop is where we
stand and time is looking and quiet
alright I could take and then get an
outside passer support that passer push
I could go here okay I'm winning stuff
no let's go here okay they resigned whoo
okay 781 and first for the team who
else's
Lance is right there 49 48 44 I'm
noticing that right now be cool to have
that color-coded so you could easily
know if you're in the top twenty area
okay castles um I'm gonna pull the
bishop back I don't get anything I don't
know I just don't want to take the
knight
um yeah I guess here open up my bishops
eyes
I'm gonna be a maneuver here with my
night
hmm
Stuart they're going for a central break
you
playing this after they've weakened
their King slightly
let's go here
can test that diagonal one day
maybe I have a trick in some cases
pinpointing these two
okay that night soon going to just
occupy this square
seems like it
you
No
okay
huh
let's go here
I may want to just take that money I
think it could be really good Bishop
here and then night here no no this
night this is it's only good square more
no maybe maybe into here one day let's
kick him back first
[Music]
night here
I think is a pretty good move I don't
want to see Bishop here so easily this
is my best piece so they're gonna look
to challenge it if I do this only after
Bishop there the bishop can back up okay
well forget about that they could just
shoo my knight away but I do have this
square now so let's see that Bishop gave
up a square by attacking my knight
so a little bit of a fight over these uh
squares right now let's get to a
half-open file
Knight c4 rook e8 all very sensible
moves a flight square one day I think I
want to focus more so on piece play
first Bishop here could be a move as
well
Bishop here night here I think is good I
like my position
okay do I still like my position
I think I still like my position let's
let's go let's go here right now if this
maybe I could take here instead of just
the natural recapture do I kick that
night away
starting to scare me a little bit
I take here
you
and take here
and then kick the night or what am i
doing why did i play it like this
okay I'm giving up my dark square bishop
and now weakening dark squares this is
highly highly committal and I was
thinking I could go in here immediately
to get the dark square bishop back so
this was really foolish but I just did
these last two moves really really
foolish oh I deserve a good beating now
my opponents gonna beat me up you're
going to beat me up and I will deserve
it yep
yep I'm going to deserve the beating
for sure
[Music]
yeah I am
town
hello boy
so to say it's just gonna come down to
your time scramble who knows
on the bishop the rook not the rook this
would be that fork I don't know just do
something that feels active
uh hey here
my rook has some sight now I don't know
if feels active
my night doing by the way does anybody
know
bishop time
here spawn
you
ten
oh my goodness I got they're clean
don't take this right away oh they
resigned okay 825 866 okay 26 minutes
left man these tournaments just fly by
Ches weep
okay
not going to get too many more games in
here
they're getting the e for movin
alright I'll just play it slow now let's
be a little wild here
let's dance here alright I have my
Bishop Brown to defend if you're going
to go in that direction
here night on c4
eighty-five here okay here so you're
really going to go after me
it's really going to go after me
clean here to defend are you just gonna
knock them out see this stuff is nearby
trying to fishing-pole me
it's nearby
I am on the Queen
take here though right
that Bishop was Czech
okay
it's check first night there yes
I take now let's just go here first so
help my bishop
after this I could take twice
my LightSquared bishop if I can
Square Bishop working there going to
have to attacking my king
I don't see this guy contributing to the
attack I could eliminate this guy so
Queen rook okay the knight is circling
in
circling in let's go here first this I
could play Bishop a6 first in fact I'm
ready to get rid of the knight
in-betweener this first eliminate that
night eliminate the knight
this Simone okay do I stop this push
you
it should be winning for me
should
you
h5
okay I see a thing where my queen could
defend here
like Queen a to
on taking on g6 and then here something
my queen could defend along the diagonal
is what I'm kind of banking on a queen
pivot on a two
okay so they're kind of they're
withdrawing their I do not mind seeing
let's pull the rope off of that file
first let's insert this check
[Music]
let's go here
they still have this idea
and have my clean defend
the night is very good very very good
piece to the defender still fearful of
the battery along the H file and my
bishop is hit I'll take that pawn with
check though and then simply retreat my
bishop and get this guy rolling is now
they were close to
you know I I don't think there's an
attack against my king here
take with the clean
and to say yeah let's take with the
clean give check
hahaha
this is tough on this pond I think we'll
be hunted
maybe this actually here
bishop here to defend the pawn real
tough maybe I have to do this before
backing up as well
otherwise night here I have a lot of a
defending still ahead of me I'm just
going to have to say I'm alright if that
happens whoa they're allowing this
okay keep my bishop here probably
counter-attack if rook here watch out
for the night and hit the rook and I'm
ready to start pushing my queen even
defends the promotion Square and
eliminate that okay they're definitely
on the defensive now gonna try to get
the Queen's off I have a time edge get
that rock out of here
get to the second-ranked another night
is almost completely in a pickle let's
go here
well I almost felt like that was me
Oh No
no stalemates no stalemates Oh tough
game where we have 882 945 oh okay
under-22 go I think I have fire I think
I have fire krupka 96
let's try French defense look at the top
right there Chicago and Rebecca Harris
having a battle for the top individual
overall this is so intense I wanna I
want to be a spectator right now I want
to look to see how everybody else is
doing
[Music]
let's go here castle quick activity on
this open e-file
let's take maybe I try and hang on to
home huh
check get the light square bishop Soph
and then trying to focus on this square
no you're not allowing that hey I'm kind
of keying in on these squares right now
I like this idea
Queen on this square should be really
good it's a strong move
go here out of the pin this uh okay I
don't mind seeing that maybe I do
okay I'm gonna end up parting ways with
this pawn it's just how it is and try
and focus on these light squares well
they didn't take okay
at a central centralized do I have c5
here let's try c5 I'll take and then I
have this square to work with okay let's
go here free up all these other pieces
its offer Queen exchange oh my goodness
let's not do that again
yeah I totally missed that if he didn't
realize yeah I miss that hmm
yeah that one hurts man it really hurts
this one's a goner don't take much oh
[Laughter]
man what a shock
what a shock
it's that move did they miss calculate
here I do have
Oh
we can see that the Knight is guarding
that
oh yeah this one's like it's definitely
got yeah
I have to stop Queen here I already
missed it once
is there any hope always look at these
guys they're just waiting to do
something dangerous
clean here
keep the night
be a pest
get your pawns going man
ah man just when I thought I could maybe
do something magical
working with that
upon that
it was better
I don't know push him
I'd my king
out of a pin
you
I don't know it's a passing move
you
not quite sure what to do
try and keep the clean on getting mated
yet
I made it yet
he's Finnish oh yeah that does it okay
what can I do that's kind of a big deal
losing that pond with check and then
their night is amazing okay don't miss
that out threat next time under 15
[Music]
and now I'm playing
gambits style
all righty
and hang on to this guy or not
you
you
take take take take Bishop takes pawn
[Music]
maybe I end up going clean side castles
I'm going through with this helping out
their queen because I want to make sure
I get that pawn back
you
Bishop takes pawn like my opponent did
or could have done in the last game
I'm gonna give a check
I can't Castle queenside
oops
you
whoops they shouldn't take my night
I don't know how I complete development
because offering a queen exchange
there's Queenie for and I lose a piece
okay
[Music]
it feels really weird to this whatever
Bishop g2 castles I don't know who
it's feeling dangerous now
you
um yeah they're making me feel
bad now that's a good move
oh that's what I get for not castling
you
I don't even have a move do I
you
hikes
Shep there is a move pins and many pins
here
as my pawn at Central
do they have enough development in
oh they certainly do
they're in the tank what is the best way
I can how can i punish white really bad
Bishop check I could step up maybe
oh that's that's a clean approach I
should resign and get on with another
game yeah okay 948 one thousand
and 52 points be made up
get forth
where we adhere
okay
get a couple more games in maybe this
one should count for sure
okay something let's take here right now
yes okay
like I was able to maybe catch him in a
primo that's why he did that kind of
fast
huh they'd given me something to bite at
here
so this should be excellent
are they defending that pond
you
so moved my king over first I guess the
night was gonna
okay let's go here right now my knight
is dead so add a third attacker here
okay now I should be winning this pawn
f4 f4 here here rook here I have a fork
they're going on the offensive
here
hmm let's I let's secure my night
there's no rush
mistake
this
mine I could improve as well
um
[Music]
you want to get their best piece off
maybe king over here
you
go to
you
King up
you
rook over
look right here
Herick here I could defend like this my
night
my king let's hit three parts three
times now
okay my winning this pawn now think I am
take with the rope
are pushing these guys
majority on the queenside keep pushing
stop the brake I don't want this rook to
become active flush the King back keep
pushing
I could care less about this pawn right
now
the passer
maybe I do care a little bit about them
now I still don't hear threatening to
promote I'm going to be able to get it
I can win the king and pond ending
they resigned okay got to with that 974
1022 okay
[Music]
Oh suck
stride d5 the
when this one should count as well and
probably the last one to count for the
tournament
here and get off of the a file before it
is before you miss your chance to get
off of the a file here and then here
must go its castle
okay gotta make a break okay actually
this move if I had yeah I don't have
time
I was tempted play ee4 but I'm pretty
sure f3 is gonna hit then let's go
just back I don't know maybe I should
have went all the way back now and I'm
stopping this possibility there Bishop
isn't playing sure maybe I should have
played this move
in reply d-iii no no I'm trying to play
against this guy there sometimes this
idea to have both rooks on these squares
and put pressure here but I could defend
laterally along the rank here really in
the tank ok I take looking for that
advance its flight square rule out a g4
this may still hit ok there
reppin g4 let's get a rook on a file
that is likely to open mm-hmm okay let's
do this now oh I took a little too long
okay now
what do I do okay this night maybe like
that night night on this square
for starters step up with a rook I guess
this one oh this this break my night
also supports g5 I don't know that I
want to play g5 though as that night
would then have a big square maybe my
king should come over here to assist
yeah I see they're doing that doubling
my king will be devoted there which
night could which piece can use an
improvement let's go here they're gonna
they're gonna give a check I don't know
all right let's let's try for something
here completely white I completely lock
it my bishop is kind of stupid though
yeah
what's my bishop doing okay yeah this is
completely blocked oh now there's
sacrifices I'm really in a pickle there
might be some tricks here yeah there's
gonna be a sacker Oni
or maybe I should operate draw is this a
position up for the draw
[Music]
you
oh you could take there
you
right actually
be okay here
not really
you
you
by night somewhere
you
now to take
you
on that
you
you
okay I draw that's probably gonna be the
last one I'm in at 32 the pairings mine
to actually end 1:30 yeah they just
closed
he had that got way too locked up where
we at looks like it's going to be 5th
yeah
okay whoo oh man
intense
tense
okay yeah opposite color bishops there
at the end
still another minute to go
Wow
let's see
who else's maybe in a game now
just wait it out here
let's see where we at Lance his Lance in
a game go Lance let's check out Lance
can you get a game can you get a win in
here it looks like where we at he's
playing his black not looking good
try to win on time when on time Lance
he's down okay
I wasn't meant to be that last game
there 1050
four three two one
and
there we have it the final standings
crest book chest
taking first with 1349 points
Chagall Co fanclub 1312
as media 1296 Shema canal 1095
King chest Network finishing 1053 points
whoo
I think that's a very good result
I think
thousand not easy to
cup over a thousand points
immortal games YouTube 950 chess weebs
943 oh very close first the six seven
spots oh really really close really
really close the arab team 895 yeah it
was very close for these final three
spots as well the arab team
Chessmaster team will say
and chest TV the a57
this had to be a real intense fight
towards the end here these three these
two as well
and yeah making up what is it just 42
more points hmm
maybe sneaking into a four-spot here
Wow okay let's let's see
first of all
let me say good games all first of all
the games all
yes let us see so fourteen chest network
in the end 678 competed
and top was lands 5500 with 66 Augusto
1962 had 16
I had 16
[Music]
identify as cm at 56 coke Fisher 56
night 1 5 4 7 had 55 and you could see
them all right here
this was the top 20
so all of these points added up
gets us here
and we could see a little bit more shows
the top 15
bugzilla
sticking out there and I am 28th
forty three points
guess you need around 40 points Sulekha
like
crossovers there as well
a lot more probably joined the team
since where while I was playing so I'll
have to have a look at that Wow
Wow very good turnout very good turn out
how many ended up competing who 4013
were in there where did I finish
finished in 40th
let's see let's maybe go through the top
100 pages not 100 pages top 100
or 200 let's go through the top 200 and
you could get a sense of where
everyone else
finished
age okay page one
each too
a lot of as you would expect Chris book
chess club and
Galka fanclub Wow I mean that's really I
mean that's really really close
not a huge gap 37 points I think the
last time there was a 200 point gap
between first and second so I thought it
would be a bit more competitive
this streamer battle and it was
page three there's Lance
for the team
do an all-out berserk nearly he went 85%
berserk he played 34 games
Congrats Lance thank you for playing
let's see
in theirs augusto 1962 finishing second
for the team 39th overall which is
that's very good four thousand players
in there in there at 40th
well
identify as CM is in there
putting up 56 points finishing 69
Congrats coke Fisher 72 over all night
tu-154 777th overall
gyoon a user
99
good spot you can say top of 100 Rondo
110 putting up 53 points
be gala P 119th
lagus 124 position 124 house martell
position 129 w CES finishing 137 Landau
96 and society sincerity rules 148 149
not-not-not whoa
that's a very good finish 1994 rated
maybe a new account and just the rating
has yet to catch up with strength very
nice
even this one right here the black storm
playing for chess media very nice sub mm
player putting up 50 points there may
have been other ones that I overlooked
but they you know those are those to
kind of stick out there very nice and
just a few more pages Han Hagen
finishing 174th Congrats
fr seven seven one two seven finishing
188 and this is the rest this is all I'm
gonna go through the top 200 there you
have it yeah this was this was a lot of
fun there was a lot more people jumping
in there
what was it around 2000 at the time of
the tournament when it began in the end
4000 plus all right again good games all
that was great
[Music]
you